when we started making these videos I
sort of felt that the periodic table was
about as complete as it would get
element and Pentium elements 115 and
it's been a real surprise the frequency
at which the discovery or synthesis of a
new element has been announced and a few
days ago we had the announcement that
the original experiment for making
element 115 had been repeated by a
different group and this greatly
increases the chances that element 115
will actually get a name
[Music]
originally groups from the Institute in
Dubna in Russia and the Lawrence
Livermore Lab in the States collaborated
to make element 115 the way they did it
was a method which many of you who
regular viewers may be becoming quite
familiar with you take a healthy element
and the light element and by
accelerating the light element it bangs
into the heavy element so fast that
every so often and not very often the
two nuclei fuse so in this case you take
americium element number 95 calcium ions
going really fast
element number 20 20 plus 95 makes 115
if we do it properly
you can see they should fuse together
it's quite a hard process but here you
have the combined nucleus 115 when I
bought this toy dog toy I didn't think
I'd be using it so much so here's the
new element now the way that these are
detected is by the nuclear decay which
gives out sometimes alpha particles
sometimes gamma rays and you can predict
quite well how these elements are going
to decay here the decay chains of some
of the lower number elements the reason
why I've got this tie is that this is
from the German Institute GSI the heavy
iron Research Institute and the new
paper has come from a group of Swedish
scientists and and a professor Dirk
Rudolph who has done essentially a very
similar experiment calcium plus
americium but on the german accelerator
and they have detected the emission of
gamma rays which may be x-rays depending
on the precise wavelength as these decay
but the important point is
that we now have a repeat of the
original experiment so that the evidence
all been well will be much stronger for
the existence of element 115 so what
happens now
is that the evidence is submitted to a
committee a joint committee of the
International Union of physics and the
International Union of pure and applied
chemistry and they discussed the
evidence and if they're satisfied then
the discoverers and I'm not sure whether
it will be the first group or the second
group or perhaps both are allowed to
choose the name what that means for my
mug is that we should be able to fill in
the blank space between element 114 and
116 and just like hundred 14 has the
name florium and 116 is livermorium
there's an opportunity for an
interesting name in between I still
quite like the name Planck iam after Max
Planck because I think Planck M is nice
and short and easy for everybody to say
but I'd be interested to hear what you
think should be a good name remember
that it has to be named after a
scientist who is dead so if you litt
name a living scientist is sort of
condemning them to death which is not
very nice and but there is a real
opportunity to celebrate something that
is not too nationalistic it should be
said about this discovery being led by a
Swedish team that Sweden has quite a
good track record of discovering
elements there's the element scandium
that was discovered and they're also my
scientific ancestor Berzelius discovered
several elements and of course the
famous quarry in Italy has led to the
discovery of many new elements
so Sweden is quite a hotbed of these
discoveries so it is quite nice and
perhaps the element will end up with a
Swedish name but it would be nice to
have something that was more
international trubiz alias have an
element yes bazillion would be quite
nice and but the symbol but I suppose
the symbol could be busy so let's see
what they say whenever we do a video
about this people suggest Polikoff iam
like jokingly or serious whatever you
said one has to be dead you have an
element named after them we've also
heard people say that many chemists
think having an element named after them
is a great honor would you be willing to
trade in any years on earth in exchange
for an element no I don't think so and
so many people have difficulty
pronouncing my surname it would be a
dreadful name for an element nobody be
able to pronounce it and also and most
importantly I have done nothing for the
discovery of the new elements and so I
don't deserve such an honor anyway just
just a message for the people named in
the elements I am open to the idea I've
had nothing to do with it but you have
reham hariom radium I take it you take
it
perhaps YouTube young YouTube you have
done nothing